[Applause]
justin poirier turning down that title
fight so he could go fight
connor for the real title cash is king
you know he gonna make millions of
dollars i think that's the right thing
to do
you can get that belt and you can fight
against chandler or oblivera it's
probably going to be oliveira not
chandler
but nobody's going to care about that
oliveira fight they care when conor
first red panty fight
that what red panty fight that red panty
fight what's that what's mcgregor say he
said bust out the red panties you're
fighting me you're going to be rich
oh [ __ ] red panties is like linger
yeah lingerie that launcher i don't get
it
that's what mcgregor says my name is
[ __ ] okay your girl don't got some fancy
pants
yo come on boy she ain't busting him out
for ufc fights
yeah but what's your equivalent of ufc
players yeah
when we go go-kart racing yeah like if
you won go-kart racing you know she's
busting out the launcher
yeah yeah yeah he knows you're busting
out the longest could you ever be your
girl a go-kart racing i probably could
i i damn near the wrench in her car i'm
gonna bring her up
i'll throw a wrench in a spoke if you
know i'm giving i'm giving a whole pep
talk when i go home what i say yo
we're going out there thursday we're
about to get it yeah yeah
i'm telling her that [ __ ] too now that
you're gonna play mario kart yeah
yo now that you're getting a pep talk
we're gonna be training no we gotta
literally go at it
al you're going to be the lewis hamilton
of this race oh you already know
how do you feel about that gay
[Laughter]
that's a legit bro yeah bro
but he's also allegedly taking down riri
rihanna who has it
right though like right though you
haven't i haven't
yeah oh [ __ ] y'all have it i got clothes
are you close yeah
when did you almost take down riri yeah
when you went
when you bought the fenty for your girls
yeah yeah yeah oh that was yeah yeah
wait for real no you guys know no i
didn't i don't even know
how expensive that [ __ ] is i never
bought makeup for anyone in my life
same for anyone
you bought some fenty yeah bought some
fentanyl can you buy your girl makeup
for your
thing no not for you for your for your
sister
yeah and for your shorty too no my
sister because it's only for black women
right
no fenty you could be white and you yeah
you can get out of here yeah what do you
think doloz all uses son come on oh
that's a good ass point yeah
right that's good that's my willow shout
out to rihanna but back to this fight
i think i hate to say it
i don't think conor has it in him
anymore
to train the way that he needs to train
in order to win this fight over and over
i think it's what is the great marvin
hagler quote
everyone has a plan to like get punched
in the face that's not it's tyson what
is the great marvin hagler quote yeah
uh i don't know it's hard to wake up and
run in the morning
when you're sleeping
or silk pajamas but that's that's the
same quote something like that basically
means the same thing
right but when you're sleeping in those
silk pajamas it's hard to wake up and
run and do at road work six a.m
i think conor has enough discipline to
do enough
to look good on the scale yeah the
muscles will look good he knows how to
hype the fight and he knows he can make
millions of dollars off this fight
but i don't know if he wants it enough i
don't know if he's starving enough i
don't know if he's
why does he need the money he's rich
he's i will say this
if he can beat dustin and
oliveira or chandler doesn't matter who
wins their fight
for the belt let's say conor beats
dustin
then conor beats chandler oliveira
whoever wins that fight
conor is the champ again i think
proper 12 when he's the champ increases
its value by
minimum 50 maybe 100 percent
okay that's fair so if he has a hundred
million dollars
in that company those ufc fights that
might pay him five million
ten million those five tens
actually give him a hundred million in
alcohol i have no data to back this up
but
i'm talking about the worth of that
company is tied to his success
as a fighter and if he has the belt
again [ __ ] are at the club
or in proper 12 at the bar order in
proper 12.
so if he can look forward to that 100
million if he can go that's what i'm
fighting for it's not really this fight
against dustin it's not even the fight
for the belt
it's the fight to make proper 12
on top top yeah maybe that's enough
motivation i don't think it is
i don't think it is but he could make an
exorbitant amount of money
not in the fights but in his companies
if he's able to hold it together for two
more fights
and i mean if he comes back and becomes
champ again
i mean legacy wise it's like [ __ ] dude
make the
make the movie especially you come back
from the knockout and also now you start
selling the story where it's like
connor always comes back from defeats
cause he came back
nate tapped him out yep then he won
their next fight i mean it was close
fight but he did win the next fight
so then he takes out dustin you look
takes out oh
connor knows how to prepare he knows how
to find what you're doing wrong and
exploit it
say again did he win fights after khabib
this is maybe yeah he fought um
cowboy cerrone okay yeah he'd be a
cowboy cerrone
um i mean dude if he
beats both of them gets the belt again
there's even a mayweather play if he
wants it
wants it right or
maybe pacquiao who the [ __ ] knows but
he's got to get those
do you think a jake paul fight would
make more money than a mayweather fight
if he knocks out
ben askren oh if he knocks out ben
askren make more money than they would
wait what are you asking i'm saying if
if jake paul knocks out ben askren
connor becomes champ is he is it a
bigger money play to fight mayweather or
to fight jake paul
no mayweather probably will always be
bigger but
uh it is a tricky one if if if jake
knocks out ben askren and then fights
one more mma guy who's actually got
decent hands
like he goes in there with an mma guy
who's known for having
okay hands ben askren is known for
having no hands
but a guy who's had some knockouts like
let's say he fights a donald cerrone or
something like that
and then he goes in there and like
actually knocks him out as well
like he i mean that'd be crazy now he
can fight connor
yeah yeah mike perry if he fights mike
perry and then he [ __ ] up mike perry
crazy literally he has his pick of
anybody in mma mike perry be a good
fight too sales wise yeah
this is what i was thinking about
mcgregor and mayweather
i don't know if mcgregor wants to do
what he had to do to sell the first
fight
which would be the absolute heel the
[ __ ] you pinstripes and that you can't
read and
[ __ ] just he don't seem like
i don't know if he wants to fight or not
but it seems like he doesn't need feel
like he needs to do that [ __ ] anymore
i'm rich enough that i don't have to do
all that will he want to do that again
for mayweather money jake paul will sell
the fight in his own jay paul is
very well versed in being the heel and
whatever and you could be likable
mayweather and you can have a payday and
you're fighting somebody that's
way less of a boxer i'll be honest with
you i think i'm on your on your side on
this like
not only is it easier there's maybe more
interest
because we know you can't beat
mayweather yeah we don't know
that you can 100 beat jake especially if
jake knocks out a couple mma guys yeah
i mean that's there you go there's the
trajectory you win both of those fights
you get proper 12 to the moon you have
the belt
your legacy is completely cemented you
have an amazing movie made about your
life
you jake paul beats asgrin beats maybe
another person who's got decent hands
you do a mega fight in boxing if you
beat jake you beat jake if you don't if
you know it doesn't matter if you don't
jake is a [ __ ] superstar forget about
it
if you do you beat up the youtuber and
you made 100 million dollars in the
process there's the next three years of
your life connor go for it